never before has there been so much
amazing entertainment programming on
Netflix HBO Amazon FX and basically
everywhere this explosion is great for
us viewers but the costs could lay waste
to Hollywood and Silicon Valley about
500 scripted series are expected next
year on broadcast television cable and
web streaming services that's about
double the number of shows aired in 2010
with the biggest increase coming from
Netflix Amazon Hulu and the like the
entertainment industry has a term for
this content boom peak TV at peak TV
ain't cheap six of the biggest
entertainment companies will spend about
twenty seven billion dollars combined to
make or buy TV series and movies this
year netflix gets most of the credit or
the blame for this content bubble and
Netflix will either be the biggest
beneficiary of peak TV or its biggest
victim the company alone expects to
spend about six billion dollars in 2017
on programming nearly double its content
costs in 2014 but can the company afford
this shopping spree
Netflix owes more than 14 billion
dollars in the next few years to pay for
its TV shows and movies that programming
tab is about 36 times the cumulative
cash Netflix has generated since it went
public 14 years ago and the other big
question is who will watch all these new
shows younger people are spending less
time with traditional TV and even
Netflix and Amazon are fighting for our
free time with new entertainment options
like YouTube Facebook and snapchat so
enjoy the war for our eyeballs while the
good times lasts because if there's a
tiny stumble it could make them all cut
back on programming and that could bring
the tech and entertainment industry's
house of cards tumbling down
you